here
all right um everyone the time being
10:05 we'll get
started and first up I will open the
1203 and I think uh representative alme
Bill thank you Mr chair
chman
uh Susan uh representative Susan elme
Grafton
17 on Le city of
Lebanon and I'm introducing this bill on
House Bill 1203 relative to prohibiting
the charging of rents to Charities by
charitable Gaming facilities um which is
sponsored by Michael Cahill
and um he is in another committee and I
have a statement from him I'd like to
just read briefly into the record um Mr
chairman members of ways and means I'd
mine do you know how to turn it
[Laughter]
off it's in the pocket of the
purse
well we'll find the phone sooner or
later oh still
going
sorry Mr chairman members of ways and
means I'd like to thank you for the
courtesy extended to me due to the
scheduling of another bill in another
committee at nearly the same time this
morning uh special helps thanks to
representative Susan elme for
introducing hb23 on my behalf like
anyone not directly involved with the
participating Charities or gambling
facilities I was not aware that rent was
being charged and the Charity's proceeds
reduced by hundreds of dollars
considering that the benefit to the
Charities was in large part why the
legislature allowing charitable game
rooms was approved it seems
contradictory to charge them rent I
understand that an amendment to sb12
containing language that ends this
practice and that this was approved by
this committee and that further action
is pending in view of this I'm
requesting that
hb123 be reviewed and held in the event
it is needed representative Michael K
Hill Rockingham
um as uh most of us know it's uh sb12 is
being held in Senate Ways and
Means
um indefinitely at this
point so thank you
okay I'm assuming no one has any
questions for representative elme okay
is there anyone else who would like to
testify on HB
1203 okay do we have do we have a pin
up thank you Mr chairman members of the
committee for the record my name is
Alysa margolin and I'm here on behalf of
the New Hampshire Center for nonprofits
uh we're the Statewide Association of
the nonprofit sector in New Hampshire
and um work uh to provide um excellent
programming and to be serve as a voice
for the charitable sector we would like
to express our support for um
hb123 we also supported um
representative duet's uh uh proposal and
amendment to s sp12 that um repeals
friends charged to charity and
charitable gaming and um we also wanted
to register our support for
representative kahill's proposal as well
um just uh taking this opportunity to
share some key points uh about the why
we support rent repeal um just a good
reminder every now and then that we have
gaming in New Hampshire to support the
charitable sector um and uh that is why
um we are uh allowed to engage in gaming
to support on our Charities and these
are charities who are providing
essential services and enriching our
communities um in many ways the growth
of gaming the revenue going to Charities
has become um integral to uh Mission
delivery and um A disruption in that
Revenue stream at this point would be
highly disruptive to the charitable
sector the charging of rents um uh has
been uneven across the state uh in some
places a a very small percentage of the
overall overall Revenue received from
charitable gaming in some places has
been up to
50% um we've heard reports from some of
our members and stakeholders that they
were not aware that they were going to
be charged rent and in some place some
uh times receiving an invoice only after
the fact I'm very
surprised um charitable uh sponsors of
gaming operators often feel like they
don't have a strong voice in the
transaction they're obviously um in a
position uh where they're uh very
grateful to um access this uh this
Revenue um and so push back becomes
difficult in those uh situations and so
it's even more important that the New
Hampshire Center for nonprofits can give
voice to these
Charities um and uh for those reasons um
we urge your support for this bill and
thank you for um for holding it uh in a
in a way that uh sustains this uh
important proposal thank you and I'm
happy to take any questions thank you do
Le thank you um my question is about
your statement at the end that Charities
kind of hesitate to ask questions they
feel like they don't have a strong hand
in the
conversation um to your understanding
how did the Charities get selected Ed to
participate so um our understanding is
that once the Charities are licensed
they apply to uh they seek out um
available days with gaming operators um
in some places particularly where there
is a lot of Revenue available there are
waiting lists and it's um it's not clear
uh how those are prioritized um in uh in
other places there are available days
particularly the smaller gaming
operators
and um the gaming operators and
Charities really need each other right
cuz you need a a charitable sponsor um
but the there um there is a lack of
transparency around the selection
process and often can take some advocacy
um to to secure those days once those
are secured and up up to 10 days um you
know Charities often renew uh you know
cultivate that relationship with the
gaming operator and and try to renew
those every year here may I have a
followup followup
so the is it would the fear on the
Charity's part be if I ask too many
questions or if I push back or if I get
this invoice and am taking a in call and
complain or ask a question maybe I will
get pushed to the end of the line on
waiting or maybe I won't be selected to
participate at all that's an excellent
observation representative in fact we've
heard of cases where where um Charities
have been called to um where the um the
gaming operator is asking who plans to
to uh hold an event at our facility this
year just checking as we you know and I
I honestly think that um there's no
malevolence there I think that they're
trying to engage in good marketing
practices and that it's kind of up to us
to kind of clarify those relationships
and and put some sunlight in the process
um but yes I mean uh just like any um
kind of corporate donor relationship you
know you're really looking to um to to
ensure uh you know uh a a solid um uh
partnership there um yet sometimes we
forget that it's the Charities that
legally are carrying that license so
that we can engage in gaming operations
and then you know in many ways that are
the gaming operators who have done the
investing and the capital development so
that more Revenue can be to uh can flow
to charity so there's an appreciation
there as well thank you very much thank
you representative PL yes I see a paper
in front of you is that something no I
don't have um written testimony this
morning I knew this was a repeat bill
but I'm happy to submit um draft
something and submit it to uh to the uh
clerk yes be happy to do that you're
welome represent um and uh this is not
not a question for her it's a statement
I happen to be on the lion sight and
hearing Foundation of New Hampshire Inc
and we've received charitable gaming so
I'm directly at least my organization is
directly affected by this and I have to
just disclose that thank you
brother
Aly thank you um I'm beginning to wonder
how many
uh on legislators are on the boards
of of ch ities that get perhaps
preferentially um um slotted into to a
week to 10
days I have I have no idea I can't
answer that question thank you
representative thank you representative
Southworth uh thank you for taking my
question it may be for the group as a
whole too um has anyone tried to
estimate how much money is lost to the
Charities uh under the current rent
practices I think that's a great
question I don't know the answer perhaps
someone from the New Hampshire lottery
does I know that we have Representatives
here today thank you thank you yes
representative
fellows thank you
um I'm when I look at this bill it makes
me wonder how many of the uh casinos
that are
currently um operating on behalf of the
Charities are going to just stop because
they're not going to get the revenue
from the rent this says that um they
they can't charge for use of their
equipment so I'm
wondering how how how is this going to
impact it overall do you think yeah
thank you for the question and as I just
mentioned you know obviously there's a
reciprocal relationship here those
gaming operators have invested in the
machinery and the locations and all the
marketing um my understanding and it
would probably be better to ask them but
my understanding is that the gaming
operators Association supports rent
repeal and that was uh shared uh during
um representative uh duet's amendment to
sp12 yes that's it's a good thing to
point out we so when we went over
representative duett's Amendment on sp12
the retain bill
sp12 um we passed that out of committee
and it is now in the we passed it on the
house floor as well it's in the Senate
so this this and we're going to hear a
couple of other bills they are
components of what is in the retain Bill
questions seeing none thank
you and we'd like to find the
whereabouts of that pink card I um
anywhere um yeah so I hate to have you
fill out another one but uh if we can't
find
it uh is there anyone else I don't have
yes good morning my name is Valerie King
with New Hampshire lottery I just had
two things I do have one copy of
document that uh separates how much rent
is compared to their overall I can
provide this if you'd like it ranges I
only have it by room not a total average
but it ranged from about 5% to some of
the bigger rooms to as much as 50% to
some of the smaller rooms so I can
provide that um the other thing I just
wanted to point out is in
um in reenacting section 19 the writer
inadvertently remove the requirement
that 35% go to charity so they'll want
to put that back in otherwise it doesn't
statute which bill
so this is this is for um it's RSA 287
d19 Roman number number two parenthesis
a is where the current language is where
it refers to the 35% going to charity
they'll want I I it also refers to the
rent and I think they took the whole
thing out rather than just the rental
piece what what Bill did that oh this is
House Bill
you Mr chairman yes since the lottery
has brought that particular question up
will representative K Hill be asked to
put an amendment into
this to this bill or is that covered by
what representative du setad well it's
we we don't have to ask him to do it we
can put the amendment okay
yeah
um fellows do you have a question
okay all right um are there any other
pink cards that I do not have anyone
else wishing to
testify okay seeing none I will close
1203 given that it is not 10:30 yet we
will have a little break until we start
chair
e
all right the time being 10:32 we'll get
started
again I'm going to open the public
1255 and we
will hear from uh rep excuse me
representative Aly who will introduce
the
Bill thank you on representative Susan
elme uh city of Lebanon Grafton 20 uh
Grafton
17 I keep forgetting that number um I am
introducing House Bill
1255 from representative hor Oregon of
straford 10 relative to the historic
horse racing
moratorium um the bill extends the
moratorium on issuance of new historic
course racing licenses from 2024 to
2026 and um I will take no
questions because uh but the uh sponsors
um uh has a family problem and could not
appear thank thank you for introducing
the bill I have no other pink cards
would someone else like to testify on
this
we have plenty of
time I should have allocated five
minutes for this um we do have his
testimony we do have his
testimony
I
here obviously you can uh review his
testimony and we'll have a work in exec
session on this um some point in the
future but for the purposes of the
public hearing I will close the public
hearing now on HB
um given that the next public hearing is
11: a.m. you now have 25 minutes to take
a
break
e
the time being 1106 we will get
started I'm going to open the public
and uh representative uh Ron Dunn will
Bill thank you Mr chair good morning Mr
chair committee members and guests I'm
representative Ron Dunn from lonary and
today I'm here as sponsor in a bill that
would allow local uh lottery winners to
remain anonymous this issue was brought
to my attention by a constitu
currently 18 states allow lottery
winners to remain anonymous some have
restrictions and some have no limits at
all for example in Delaware any prize
amount is Anonymous in Virginia it has
to be over 10
million uh there are several positive
outcomes uh to remaining Anonymous um it
can protect the winners from being
targeted by criminals and unscrupulous
people asking for money it can prevent
fraud and Corruption by ensuring
integrity and transparency in the
lottery system it can protect winners
privacy and personal safety as well as
their mental and emotional well-being it
limits the powers of others by
controlling what they know and how they
use their personal data it protects
winners reputations and social
boundaries think about it if you won the
lottery would you want to have an
opportunity to remain
anonymous if you choose to tell people
that's your
choice um there's several tragic stories
where lottery winners have lost their
lives or face danger um after people
find out out that they won the
lottery one example in 2009 a man who
won $30 million was shot and killed by a
woman who befriended him and tried to
take his money in 2016 a man won 400,000
in the Georgia Lottery and was shot and
killed in a home invasion when the
robbers demanded his
winnings these are just some examples um
privacy is essentially who we are as
human
beings we make decisions about every day
private is also a key element of
ensuring human dignity safety and
self-determination the Fifth Amendment
of the United States Constitution
protects rights of individuals to avoid
self-incrimination which means that they
do not have to reveal information that
could be used against them in a criminal
case revealing Lottery wom's identity
could expose them to harassment threats
lawsuits this could amount to a form of
self-incrimination James Madison
supported privacy and the Bill of Rights
he believed that the constitution
separation of
powers already protected personal
freedoms but he wanted to add an extra
layer of security by adding the biller
rights Madison is the father of
Constitution and the main author of the
Bill of Rights supported privacy and the
fundamental rights of people to remain
private thank you for your attention
today if anyone has any questions be
happy to take
them represent PL yes thank you uh M
representative done I saw you reading
from a script may I have that
sure and I put an asteris next to your
name testimony provided
sure representative elme thank you um I
think I heard you mention that this
would improve the Integrity of the
lottery how would it do that since it
would um make it possible for someone
that was the friend of the head of the
lottery for instance to win five times
in a
row thank you for the question I think
that it would allow people people
remaining Anonymous would allow them not
to I guess
be exposed to corruption or people that
uh try to do bad things to them so I
think that would improve the Integrity
of it but I guess it depends on how you
it
yes represent elbow thank you Mr
chairman thank you for taking my
question I'd like to ask you to play
devil's advocate for a moment why should
we not allow privacy here what are the
privacy I would say that's what we allow
now so it allows I would say to Devil's
Advocate the M own bill is it
transparency you're recording who has
won the
you
I mean it does seem from representative
aly's uh question
that you don't you don't have
transparency on on the lottery side of
things now because if we don't know who
won is there a concern that we don't
know
how transparent how correct the whole
process is working because there there'd
be no no one would ever know did anyone
oh somebody won and we have no idea I
mean how would you address that concern
thank you for the question uh right now
it's working in 16 other states
and I guess it's just a different
opinion I just feel like it allows um
privacy of the of the individual um so
they choose they get to choose whether
or not they disclose what or not they
not representative ORS thank you Mr
chair thanks for taking my question
representative so I know we had a case
here in New Hampshire a couple years ago
I believe and judge Charlie Temple was
the judge on that case and the
couple I don't know if it was a couple
the person that won wanted this privacy
issue so is there a way to maybe have
the courts or somebody certify that
there is a winner to answer the question
that's coming from rep Aly or PL that at
least we know there is a winner it's
been certified by somebody in the court
you you know the documents are sealed so
maybe that would be a good amendment to
this thank you for the question I would
have no objection to that sir okay thank
you uh representative fellows thank you
Mr chair um when I read this it it's a
little bit confusing to me and I think
it's because of what happens when you
try to not mess with the existing
language too much and stick something in
there but it it almost reads to me as if
if suppose a person signs a form they
don't want their name released totally
understand that but it the way I read it
it seems like they can't the lottery
can't release the date of the prize and
was thank you for the question any
wording that you object to I would have
no problem amending it's just what the
what the lawyers told me we had to have
in it so yeah
maybe if you could if you could just
follow up with them on that and see if
you know if they understand what I was
you understand what I was saying
absolutely and just make that clear I
think may I think maybe it could be re
it could be written better I'd
absolutely do that thanks thank you
representative El me thank you on do you
know how long the states that are doing
this have been doing it and is anybody
studied uh the effect of it other than
cre creating privacy for the individual
thank you for the question I know the
states but I don't know how long but I'd
certainly willing to find that out for
you and get that information back to the
committee representative PL yes
representative done uh are there audits
taking place of the lottery and uh would
would an audit uh provide uh I guess
some light of day if if if was some
inside game we were operating with
Lottery employ won several times
wouldn't that come to light a day yes it
would thank you for the question yes it
would
sir yes representative roachford thank
you Mr chairman um just looking at the
bill and
um the way I have read it thus far I
mean there is the ability for confidenti
confid confidentiality as is says you
know the payment of prize as provided in
the section shall be
confidential and they won't be subject
to RSA
91a and they shouldn't be they they
won't be released until upon written
request so way I read that it looks like
it's you're just adding a different form
that has to be filled out in order
to to authorize the Lottery Commission
but the way I understand it now the
Lottery Commission can only release that
and they're here today maybe they'll be
testifying unless the winner does
authorize them to do so is that I guess
I'm wondering if you know what what
further steps you're um you know lines 8
through 12 do to to provide for that
thank you for the question I will defer
to someone that has more knowledge than
do yes represent Mr chairman will the
director of the lottery be yes
presenting thank you I'll wait till his
okay sounds good saying no other
you and uh next I do have the director
McIntyre uh good morning Mr chairman
members of the committee I'm Charlie
McIntyre director Lottery uh good
morning um I find myself in the position
of opposing this bill certainly um it'll
make our job more difficult and
obviously less transparent and what I
mean by that is more difficult for
example there are a number of games we
run which we do promotions or drawings
publicly uh we've done a number at the
NASCAR track where a bunch of folks are
pulled from a larger pool on stage and
somebody wins a million dollars on stage
super fun event super popular super not
possible with this law um because then
I'd have to I don't have to disclose
them put have a blank screen over them I
I don't know how to do that um so we'd
stop doing those um moreover this bill
would suggest that I'm able to hand out
hundreds of millions of dollars annually
in
secret um and obviously as you folks may
or may not know there was a process by
which a number of ways folks can go
through and claim the prize via trust
and that is is not subject to disclosure
in terms of the trust done correctly and
we assist people on that way and to
representative AR point about the um
lawsuit we had uh we had suggested to
the winner that they file suit only
because we had received word from the
Attorney General's office that because
they had signed the back of the ticket
in person that that was their remedy we
didn't wasn't a adversarial litigation
it was just you should go to court and
get an order if you get an order we
happily comply with it
due diligence was done to make sure the
person was eligible to win because there
are a number of individuals who are
ineligible to win as you can imagine the
folks who work with me at the lottery
are ineligible to play the lottery who
would believe I won Powerball fairly
right you know let's be honest here um
and more importantly my mom who you know
has passed but used to play the lottery
uh who would believe she won fairly um
and so for all those reasons I I would
suggest we were not in favor of this
bill at this time time um for those
reasons and welcome any questions thank
you representative shamber thank you Mr
chairman thank you director for taking
this question lines 12 and 13 of the
bill financing statements filed with the
commission shall be public records uh
what are these filing statements
composed
of should that be corrected spelling too
statements I have to admit I don't know
where that refers to I'd have to check I
don't know this refers to okay thank you
Mr followup question Mr chairman follow
up will you send us a to the chairman
the answer to that yeah of course what
course representative roachford yes
thank you Mr chair
so going back to my question I had with
the um Prime sponsor the the way I
understand it there is the option and I
may understand it incorrectly that would
not be the first time um the way I
understand there it appears that there
is an option for confidentiality as as
is correct now is that with the trust or
is that even over aside from the trust
well certainly the there's the technical
and then there's the real reason if
somebody walked in here and said listen
I'm a victim of domestic violence please
don't release my information we wouldn't
do that just as a matter of courtesy and
second we talk to folks when they come
and claim and say you you have the
rights to not if you don't if it's a
problem please tell us and they that's
respected okay so during and we claims
as you can imagine we cut thousands of
checks a year so this is a conversation
held repeatedly so follow follow so if I
happen to stop at Cumberland Farms on my
way home tonight buy a lottery ticket
yes win the $100 Million jackpot I could
you question oh represent ORS thank you
Mr chair thanks for taking my question
so if I understand correctly if they
choose to remain anonymous don't sign
the back of the ticket whatever it's
Anonymous correct okay if you sign the
back of the ticket well there are prizes
for which Anonymous so everything over
$600 we have
to announce to the IRS that you've won
over $600 okay it's there's technical
reason but six no over $5,000 we have to
withhold 24% of the prize winnings pay
on behalf of you tell the IRS you and
then send you a w2g so it's not
Anonymous the IRS knows you've won yeah
um but yeah okay very good thank you I
mean as you can imagine we don't want to
cause a problem obviously but we also
want to promote the fact that folks
actually win that it's not
secret so we're trying to it's as you
can imagine it's a tough Balancing Act
we understand that there are issues
related to it but you know knock on wood
because I'm superstitious uh we haven't
had any issues like that in in this
state that I'm aware of we've had three
winners in the last six years over
hundred
million and um and over a billion
dollars and winnings candidly uh and
certainly no major issues like that I
will tell you
99 out of 100 times the person gives
themselves up before we ever do because
when you buy a Ferrari it or you lease a
gulf stream it it tends to show so
that's usually the issue not us it's
they bought a really nice car or you
know they bought a house Etc so so what
is the process for staying Anonymous I
mean do you fill out a form or usually
that's done over claims when the claims
process when you come in and talk to the
people um and obviously for the larger
ones we end
up um Mr Shaheen has built a wonderful
business for himself and his Law Firm
they represented a number of large
winners they come in and file a trust
there's a specific way to do it uh that
Shields you from acknowledgement so um
but we there's a conversation held
during the process and folks we we do
alert folks that you may your name may
be known is that okay um over a counter
when they claim okay thank you yes
represent War you to followup uh thank
you Mr chair would you believe that Dave
roachford and I are gonna become great
tonight all right um anybody else yes
represent shamber thank you Mr chairman
uh you mentioned
that they can remain anonymous what
happens if within your the directory
they are the ones that release the name
someone within your organization is
there a a disciplinary
procedure I if somebody has made made
reference to not wanting to be published
Anonymous I don't it's never happened so
I there was no process in place
currently I'm aware
of represent fellows can you tell me
what other states do to um prevent names
being released the process that they use
uh it varies by state I'd have to get
you list I haven't checked on it
recently uh this is an issue with across
the country this up every so often um
the most famous case is there's a case
out of Australia where a boy was held
Ransom um it's called Grahams law it's
in Australia um I tend to favor on the
side of transparency um but I I can get
you a list of whatever each state does
it certainly
try follow up I I'm just
asking um other states have a process
for a person to remain a non onymous
some I'm looking for something that
might be easier than telling them they
have to set up a trust okay I I can get
you that
yes I mean certainly the easiest process
would be so if I could suggest um have a
box on the claim form saying I don't
want to be anonymous I don't want to be
that would be an easier process less
intrusive than a sheet 14o letters and
never having a public event like that
would be less but I can certainly list
like any other
you that's all I have for pin cards is
testify oh
okay I may have found it once you
introduce
yourself
se you yeah you can
start turn on your mic
yeah all right um thank you for taking
the time to listen um my name is Sean
Faber I live in London Derry New
Hampshire
um imagine every one of us looks outside
sometimes we hear noises outside we look
outside the window um maybe something's
out there maybe something's not um we
get you know sometimes if we get really
concerned that there's people around our
house we rely on friends and family um
but sometimes you can be put in a
situation where you're not sure really
who to trust what to do and you can be
in a panic situation when they say the
winning the lottery should change your
life it shouldn't in that fashion people
shouldn't be scared scared after they
get something good people shouldn't have
to look over their shoulder or wonder
when their mom is calling or a cousin or
something is there an ulterior motive um
when you look up on the New York Post um
recommendations for winning lottery one
of the recommendations is change your
address change your phone number get a
PO Box these are recommendations that
people have to do um this bill the the
intention of it is only so you can win
the lottery there's no public disclosure
of who you are behind the scenes people
can still take a look and do all the
mechanisms to keep the lottery as secure
as it is today and the lottery is very
secure
today um just not having your name out
there not having to fear for those
things I think would make a a vast
difference in people's lives yes we
haven't had an incident in this state um
I get the lottery is a statistical
anomaly in itself um but we've had three
win here what happens if we have the
fourth and we get a case like Australia
do we want to look like the state that
we could have did something here and we
didn't do anything to prevent that um
one of my favorite things from the New
Hampshire Constitution so article 2B in
our Bill of Rights right to privacy an
individual's right to live free from
government intrusion in public or
personal information is natural
essential and inherent that is one of my
favorite Clauses in this Bill of Rights
added in 2018
and that I think is what separates us
from many other states there's 18 states
that are ahead of us on this issue and
they've found a way to do this and still
maintain the Integrity of their Lottery
um when you have things like public
displays where someone's coming up and
you have something you know at say the
Nascar event and someone comes up on
stage I think that could be a different
exception to this that's not the same
thing as buying a lottery ticket and
having something where there's no public
public display um some states have
gotten around that by having a certain
dollar value they put conditions on how
you collect anonymously so maybe that
could be an amendment to this but I
think just to protect our citizens to
protect our constitutional right for
privacy in the state this is a very
important thing to get worked out and
not leave as is I don't think an
individual to exercise their rights of
privacy should have to get a trust I
don't think they should have to um go to
a lawyer who could financially benefit
from setting up these trusts um it could
be said that getting recommended to a
certain law office every time could be a
sign of something where there's a little
bit of funny business underneath the
hood so I ask you to support this bill
um maybe it could use some amendments
but we have a constitutional right to
privacy and I'd like to keep it that way
thank you thank you um I guess my
immediate question and you may not have
been able to think about this earlier
because we just heard testimony from
director McIntyre but he is saying that
you can win the lottery and remain
anonymous so does that change your
opinion of the necessity um if you are
able to Lin the lottery without going
through a trust because I'm well aware
of that um you can go through and set up
that's a lot of legal hassle to have to
go through and yes you could argue well
the person can afford it they just won
the lottery but I don't think we should
have extra conditions on exercising
rights
well I guess my question is why would
you have to set up a trust there's no
requirement oh that was my understanding
of what he said maybe he I could be
wrong on that but my understanding was
the path to privacy includes setting up
a trust that's that's the way to set it
up where you are Anonymous the trust
wins the lottery not you that just my
understanding all right well we'll we'll
check on that thank you okay uh anyone
else have
questions yes representative
all thank you Mr chair and thank you for
taking my question
the issue that seems
to arise is whether or not the winner of
the
lottery in order to maintain
transparency of the action of the
lottery should be identified as a person
or
entity so that people know somebody one
who and it wasn't just paid out to
somebody else M what what is your
opinion on that position and individual
privacy because our right to privacy is
limited I think that all the mechanisms
behind the scenes that are currently
ensuring Integrity could keep ensuring
that Integrity so I'm not I'm not
worried about because I I've talked to
some people about this too and I think
the biggest concern is that well what if
you know my brother wins every single
year um there should be mechanisms
already to prevent that not just the
announcement if that's the sole thing
problems representative roer thank you
Mr chairman thank you for coming in
today um and I and I certainly can can
well I can't understand it I've never
won the lottery uh but if I ever were to
won win the lottery I I agree with you I
would I wouldn't want the whole world to
know and and you know all of a sudden
everyone's your family member and coming
out of the woodwork um but I look at the
law as it is currently and I'm just
wondering if this is if the law now is
not sufficient I don't know what this
bill is going to do so the way the law
reads right now payment of a prize as
provided in this section shall be
confidential and then it goes on to say
unless a release is signed so that's the
way it is now so what if we were to to
pass what we have here today before us
what how much more will that do I mean
it it it to me I mean I it sounds like
we we can have confidentiality without
doing a trust uh without setting up a
trust or whatnot um I just wonder what
your your thoughts are on that yeah I
think that's some sorry this is in the
way but I think that's something that
needs to be looked into as we look at
this bill um because if you look at the
states that you can win the lottery
privately we're we're definitely not
listed there's not anywhere that lists
Us in any shape or form so I imagine the
you to um I don't have any other pink
cards now this point is anyone else like
1389 all right seeing that I guess I'd
like to call director McIntyre back up
to answer the question about the trust
not certainly I know we've talked to
staff who do claims there's a number of
people who claims but it's been a number
of folks who've gone through that
process I will confirm with them that
they check with people that they're okay
with their name being
disclosed but I do know trust is
obviously the way guaranteed I'll
confirm for the members of the committee
that indeed it's still being done um as
I had suggested so I'll answer with the
questions as well that I've been asked
the number I've been asked as well for
the committee to confirm that okay
represent
elme thank you uh what Extra Protection
does a trust
provide um obviously there are tax
benefits
um it does shield the sort of the
knowledge of it um we've had a number of
trust candidly the vast majority of
prizes we we don't publicize because we
don't it's not worthy of a$1 th000
winner to be publicized obviously um
there may be Legacy benefits in terms of
um inherit U estate planning um I went
to the wrong side of the law school so I
don't trust law is not what I practice
we have a chief compliance officer who
reviews all trusts that come in uh who
is a former Assistant Attorney General
so I i' refer to him in terms of trust
benefits I'd way outside my over my skis
on that one yes follow
on you do have to still tell the IRS
though
right um that the trust um all of the
trust that we get of that level all have
a tax ID number and so the trust pays
the taxes as for the folks who that are
the ultimate winners I do know who they
are uh and have been ordered either
through the trust or through court order
to keep that a secret to make to make
sure that it isn't once again an
uh yes represent
ellerie thank you Mr chair um Mr
McIntyre the trusts that are that are
have made claims on that have been paid
out are those revocable or irrevocable
trusts in the primary if I recall
correctly representative thank you for
the question I think they're both
because there's been a number of them uh
we've had fundamentally every prize
almost that we've had over a million
dollars has claimed as a trust and those
are the ones as you can imagine we
actually publicized the trust I know
that sounds awkward but we'll often have
the lawyers sit with a check and hold it
and say hey thanks um so that
it's um they like so no we we public
like you know the representative Ry
trust won $10 million actually not
um the reason follow up follow the
reason I asked that question is because
an irrevocable trust is just to flow
through there is no separate Ein um or t
uh for the revocable trust whereas on
the irrevocable trust it's an entity
that takes on a life well both of them
have a life beyond my life from my my
wife's life
uh but
it's they don't need it because it's
just a flow through and after the
primaries um die then the trust is wiped
out or it goes to the other the next
person and they keep spending it down
unless they put money into it I mean
that would be the same case of an
individual who was a person who passed
you would the by the law of whether they
had a will or into in testy you you
transfer ownership of the winnings to
the next in line like for example if you
want a Lucky for Life The Lucky for Life
if you we guarantee we pay you 20 years
if you pass in five then the
laws of intestacy or by your will or
your trust would pass to the next on
line but certainly tax law once again
also not in my area so I leave it and
nor trust law representative spillsbury
thank you Mr chairman um Mr McIntyre
we've talked around this question uh
with the last several witnesses and I'm
struggling to
find in the existing statutory language
that I see here with in the bill to see
what language would allow the commission
to withhold the identity of the winner I
I I grant that the creation of a trust
allows uh a vehicle to Shield the
identity of the individual
but this first sentence lines 3 to five
doesn't in my reading say that the
payment shall be confidential
it says the financial tax trust or
personal
records shall be confidential those
financial tax trust or personal
records that are in connection with the
payment so I don't see in that sentence
or any else anywhere else here what
would allow for um for the commission to
maintain an anity even if the winner
specifically asked for it is there a
different statute that might get to that
or is this the one um I'd have to refer
back to because there the lottery exists
into two separate sections of the RSA
284 and 287 so it have to refer back to
284 uh I don't know that we did a fiscal
note on maybe we could follow up on this
and I know it's a question of
interpretation it is but my reading I
don't see a basis for
maintaining anonymity in the existing
law I certainly I don't know that the
law requires us to disclose absent it
being a 91a request which candidly I
don't think we ever get other than in
certain circumstances which really
here that's an interesting point
um in line
six uh the Third sent following the
91a says the commission may release the
name I suppose that's not mandatory um
so does that get to the question of
discretion uh in terms of the lottery
commission's practice it does I think
the certainly the the
onus the benefit to the state is
obviously disclosure of winners that
indeed were paying winners that aren't
related to me or my or the folks I work
with so um but there's no requirement I
think that we disclose absent 91a where
we were would see for example a press
inquiry of that
respect follow up so again on
interpretation the May means you
can you're not required to but it also
means that the
it from this reading it's correct but
it's not a statutory requirement it
would be coming upon us to sort of honor
with the
wishes thank you well to follow up on
that I mean this isn't the
complete uh law right in terms of
disclosure so there still maybe another
section then that yeah and certainly 91a
as well as 284 uh which I will send back
and compare I don't think we were asked
to do a fiscal note on this one so okay
certainly happy to answer the questions
back to you Mr chairman members of the
committee the number of questions that
have been asked yes to you through the
clerk thank
you Mr clerk yes after reviewing the law
as it is now if there's any Avenue where
somebody against their will would have
the their winnings
publicized is there something is there
some way mechanism you could work with
the sponsor of this bill so that that is
closed uh in a manner that that you
don't object
to Absolutely I'll look at that there's
no we want to be trans arent but we also
want to respect somebody's wishes that
are that are founded in fear so
absolutely I mean in terms of that
question um he he doesn't necessarily
work with the the sponsor of the bill he
can answer the questions the committee
the committee will potentially propose
an amendment if it makes
sense yes representative fellows th this
is right along the same whole issue this
the more I read it I think this is not
where this belongs in the statute
because I mean one of the things is it
said it it says the records are not
public records and then it says upon
request the commission may release
something I mean May release upon whose
request you know you think that's
usually the press and the last sentence
Financial financial statements filed
with the commission I'm wondering what
those even are so just I just it just
looks like it's in the wrong
place
um what is the question is it in the
wrong
place will you check on that yes no
certainly following up but represent
shamberg I think regarding financial
statements that's the same question so
19678 so it's an old law that need to be
worked representative do set thank you
Mr chair just a quick question have we
ever experienced litigation a in
relation to releasing a name I say we
the lottery the
state just the once the Powerball winner
from meramac um I shudder to disclose
even the nature of the ownership whether
it be a couple or a person um we were
sued but it was not an adversarial
lawsuit we the AG because that person
had signed the back of the ticket as you
can imagine a ticket worth half a
billion dollars you'd probably want to
sign uh they signed it in their name and
they didn't want to disclose their name
so they came they went to court judge
Temple ordered me to not disclose her
name ever and I had never have so that
would be the issue related to that
follow up and and just in relation to
this I know you said it would make your
job tougher and you gave an example
whatever but would you be against
setting a bar like we heard $10 million
you you know don't release and I'm just
curious sake of argument no certainly um
as you can imagine represent thank you
the question thousand we're not
promoting that big it's not a big win
obviously for us but 10 million 100
million um we'd love to promote those
but certainly I would submit to you that
the vast majority of the player
base agrees with they would want to be
not known
to it is a little tough to hide in New
Hampshire winning a couple hundred
million just is folks and you know they
once you you tell friends and it's not
us it's usually the friends and family
that know because you tell somebody but
we don't have no objection to that point
representative I I totally understand
it's a marketing Bonanza for the
commission I I get it I'm just trying to
navigate
ery since uh representative PL didn't
ask the
question you have permission to use my
million all
right any any other questions for the
you is there anyone else that would like
to testify on HP
1389 all right seeing none we'll close
hearing
okay
um I will open the public hearing on HB
1525 and we'll hear from the sponsor
representative
ducet thank you Mr chairman uh Fred
ducet Rockingham 25 the town of Salem
um to be real brief with this and we've
seen um a few components this this uh
1525 is in relation to the uh so-called
moratorium on
HHR uh and we spoke about uh Senate Bill
112 this morning briefly I'm going to uh
ask that we we hold on to this I noted a
uh a drafting error in
this as I read it this
morning uh and it will have to be
amended and we can revisit it but I
think we're all pretty well versed on
this
particular component
uh relative to testimony we've heard in
the past but this specifically to point
out the uh drafting eror if you
recall excuse me if you
recall uh the amendment to Senate Bill
112 it spoke to
those uh that have applied for an HHR
license up and until October
18th and in this there's a drafting
error that says those approved for an
HHR license so there may be some people
in the in the process and we allotted
for that in that amendment that we all
voted on so this will have to
be
amended any questions which line was
that on um I'm sorry maybe in two places
yeah and May apply in line8 also I have
to
look a line8 might be okay yeah
yeah any questions for representative
jet representative fellows so so where
it approved it says it says approved if
if we just basically change that to mean
that they'd applied for that's what it's
supposed to say right then repres the
bill
correct it seems to me this may just be
a simple drafting error represent
Aly what about line 9 to 11 a game
operator employer holding a license
eligible I think that's current language
if I recall correctly I think so yeah
does that interfere
with that's not contrary to the to this
bill
okay all right see no questions thank
you thank you I'll just need a pink card
P card on that okay uh is there anyone
okay seeing none we'll close the public
hb152 now hurry up and wait now we've
caught up uh we'll at um we'll take a
little break here and at 12 o'clock
we'll hear HB
[Music]
you I will open the public hearing on HB
1549 and we'll hear from the prime
ducet thank you Mr chairman uh Fred
ducet representing Rockingham 25 the
town of
Salem hb1 1549 is is fairly specific and
it's specific
to um charal
gaming uh and more specific to
tournament poker
play uh Last by Anum we raised the max
byy in I'm trying to look up that
legislation but we can't seem to find it
but we raised that maximum Buy in to
$2500 at
present those facilities that choose to
participate or hold uh non-monetary chip
value tournaments so if you buy in for a
$100 tournament the statute calls for a
20% rake and that's what the state the
Charities and The Operators take as
the the revenue from those particular
games excuse me not every room offers
tournament poker play it's fairly
limited but in those rooms that offer
the tournament poker play it's very well
received there's a demographic of poker
players uh in the state and uh in this
geographic location we get a lot of
people from northern Massachusetts into
the Southern Tier State uh
rooms what this does in effect is it
still allows for the
20% to be captured for tournament poker
play as a rake but if for some reason a
room chose to go to that maximum bet of
$2500 they wanted to hold a Super Bowl
of Poker type event and that Super Bowl
of Poker type event would draw very
specific I I play poker myself I would
never play a $2,500 poker tournament but
there are people that would do that if
the rooms chose to do so but the rake on
that at present would be
$500 for a $2500 event so it's kind of
twofold here the Charities would want
the traffic to come in and and take that
Revenue if you can pull a 100 people in
and get the 250 this would cap it at 250
for those larger you know it would be
whatever the lesser amount is 20% or I
believe it's stated the lesser amount so
we'd still get to 20% up and into
tournaments that would exceed $250 of
rake so we cap The Rake basically at
$250 I don't suspect and somebody from
the industry maybe can speak to it but I
don't suspect we'd see a lot of that at
present I'm aware of
I think there's a monthly tournament at
$250 there may be one that's bonly at
like $500 there's only certain rooms
that hold these tournaments on certain
nights of the week and whatnot but this
allows the availability if if a operator
chose to do so to go to that Max um
buying level that we approved Last by
Anum and this would just uh cap that
$50 okay thank you any questions
representative PL what is a
rake
okay come on represented PL you've been
here a long it's it's the take on the
these aren't chips of value when you go
to play a tournament you buy in say it's
a $100 entry fee for a
tournament the Chari
the operators in the state have to make
revenue from that so in statute right
now it's built out at
20% so
$20 of that $100 would be what is the
revenue for those non-monetary chips for
a poker tournament so those are the
dollars made for holding that particular
event for that particular player dollars
made by home I I I'm totally office in
this getting the money who's getting the
money the
20% well it's the break same breakdown
35% goes to the Charities it's the same
as any other table
game but un unlike if you sit at a poker
table and play and $2 poker there's no
monetary value if you if you play and I
understand it gets confusing
representative when you you buy in for
one particular doll amount $100 bill and
you get a stack of you know 10 chips
let's call
it and you play other players and at the
end of the day the money is pulled and
you come in first second third you get x
amount of dollars to hold that event
there has to be revenue for the state
for The Operators and mo most
importantly the Charities so the the
$100 Buy
in 20% of that is taken put aside the
rake uh yes representative Le
please so I just want to make sure I've
understood this correctly so it sounds
like what you're
proposing means that the rake would be
capped so it wouldn't the 20% wouldn't
just keep growing um the charity would
still get
35% of that so if the rake is not
allowed to expand at the 20% rate the
state would get less money and the
game operator
employer so instead of the rake being
$500 in the example you gave of the $25
$500 game uh it would be capped at
$250 correct so the game operator and
the
state and the charity would get less
money by definition absolutely okay but
I got it my contention is that it
probably wouldn't happen that tournament
wouldn't happen this gives them a
vehicle to if they chose to do so it
would happen at $500 rake at a $2500 Buy
in these poker players aren't going to
play that so it gives them the Avail not
only the The Operators but the players
the availability to play something as
large as as that and it caps it at that
250 so it doesn't change the percentages
that go to the Charities or the state
but in that specific circumstance it
would cap it at 250 okay yeah thank you
represent elme thank you I think I
remember you saying
previously in another situation that um
these highlevel gamblers go from state
games thank you for the question
representative and I'm familiar and I
pay attention I watch a lot of the TV
stuff in relation to Poker and there are
people that travel to play bigger stake
tournaments um but this would definitely
a a break it at $500 on on $2500 it
would negate that tournament ever
happening so this allows for the
opportunity for that I don't suspect
there's going to be a long line of rooms
that do this and some like I said
somebody else can speak to that but it
makes it available because we changed
so representative ORS thank you Mr chair
thank you representative for taking my
question so as trying to figure it out
if the rake of 20% comes off the top
Charities get 35% off the
top how how would they lose money I
guess 35% of the 20 oh they get 35% of
the 20 got it answer my question thank
you representative
fellows thank you so I I don't really
understand why you want to do this one
of the things I notice is if the um um
1,250
then that's equal you know that's where
you have it capped and so between a Buy
in of
1,250 and the max of
2,500 there's not any the both of those
send the same amount to be the rake that
split between the Charities and the
State why I
mean so I guess the the people that are
sitting at the table would like that
because they're GNA whoever wins is
going to get a little bit more
money but other than that
why thank you for the
question and like I said before and and
maybe uh somebody can testify to the
fact that th this is an opportunity to
drive traffic and the more people that
go and
participate in tournament play if they
can draw a 100 people in at even at the
1250 or
1,500 it's revenue for the Charities
hard stop the there's at present very
limited tournament play this allows for
the
opportunity to have those higher level
games and promote them and get the
peripheral business also but spe
specifically to
this at 20% with that's that's probably
one of the high and again somebody in
the industry can speak to but that's
that's a substantial
rake okay coming from a poker table and
when you st getting into these higher uh
higher fee tournaments to to go beyond
the 250 it just would negate the
possibility of somebody hosting that so
it's it's not as if
we we have to do this it allows for not
only the players to possibly participate
in that but it allows for maybe some
more traffic to get Revenue to the
Charities the state The Operators it
it's kind of a carot and stick thing you
know it's up to them to promote it I
again my personal opinion I was
approached with this by by the industry
and by players because I play poker
myself um
it it gives them the availability
because we now by Statute can go up to a
Max buying of $2500 but it's never going
to happen a tournament at $2,500 just
isn't feasible with a $500 rake it's
just follow up yeah can it's I've never
been to a poker tournament so can you
give me some kind of um help
understanding is is this five or people
sitting at one table is or is it do they
have multiple tables at the same time
and I'm just trying to figure out like
how many players would there be who are
are playing you know doing buying into
it sure sure and in my experience thank
you for the question in my experience
the more the merrier the more people we
want everybody benefits everybody
including the
player um if you're play in a tournament
normally it's a table of nine people and
they'll have depending on the size of
the particular facility and the draw for
that particular tournament um somebody
else can speak more intelligently to
what kind of numbers they're drawing but
um if you get five or 10 tables on a
weekend T that's that's great because
the prize pool grows and it makes people
want to come and play that game because
it's a bigger prize to play for and it's
a it's in an elimination kind of event
so the type of Poker we play here in New
Hampshire it's an all-in kind of Texas
hold them Allin once you lose your chips
you're done you move on to the next and
whoever's left remaining depending on
the prize pool they pay out accordingly
so the the more players the better for
all involved follow up so so if you
start out with like five tables of nine
MH when you get to the it's not who wins
per table it's it's like okay
so okay so they keep consolidating to
down to you know two tables one table
thanks anybody
else thank you thank
you okay next I have a card here for um
Alicia
Preston
hello Mr chairman members of the
committee thank you my name is Alicia
Preston I represent the New Hampshire
charitable gaming operators Association
and we are in support of this bill for
several of the reasons that
representative duet explained last year
when Senate Bill 120 was passed it
increased the buying amount for
tournament poker to
$2,500 which leaves that 20% rake um as
the rule however at a $500 Rake The
Players simply aren't going to play
these games so they're not happening
they're hasn't been one Tournament of
that level in the state of New Hampshire
since that law was passed we believe it
will actually increase the revenue to
the Charities The Operators and there by
the state because there will be more
higher level um tournaments like this so
we'll bring in more people and there
will be more tournaments happening I'm
not sure you're going to see very many
$2,500 tournaments but you may
occasionally see
you know a high-end special event at a
facility but this just makes it so that
there is a draw for players being
willing to participate if a facility
end uh represent
Aly thank you have there been
tournaments at 1500 and 12
1250 to my knowledge no to my knowledge
the highest tournament to date that I'm
aware of is
$500
questions representative PL yes if uh
$250 a cap for
$2500 uh game that's a 10% rather than
20% rake is there a problem at $500 with
a 20%
rake no be that's what people are
playing now so if there's a $500 table
there's a 20% rake people are willing to
pay that it kind of just becomes
you're putting up $2,500 knowing 500 of
that is coming right off the top that's
undesirable for a
player and I would imagine um there's
some competition with other states as
you get into those higher numbers if
we're at that level people will probably
figureing okay if I'm a higher level
player I'll go somewhere else is that
true oh absolutely and our surrounding
states do have legalized gambling so if
they can go to a $2,500 tournament in
Massachusetts and only pay $ 250 to buy
in that's where they're going to choose
choose to go as opposed to in New
Hampshire when that price is doubled
yeah okay thank you represent El
me thank you uh what if we amended the
$500 of the Buy in
amount to make the buyin amount a
minimum I'm sorry the 500 seems not to
barrier the $500 rake on a $2,500
tournament
Buy in Buy in amount to make 20% it's
now
250 it would be
500 of the Buy in amount collected from
the players whichever is less well I
think the 500 is the barrier that's why
these tournaments aren't being conducted
I thought you said that they were being
conducted at 500 oh a $500 buying I'm
sorry I'm not understanding exactly so
20 well it's at 20% for the 5 00 I guess
I'm not sure what are you talking about
the rake amount or the buying amount I'm
talking about what it says right here a
minimum of 20% or instead of 250 of the
buyin amount collected from players the
500 of the buyin
amount well that's that's what's been
prohibitive that's what's been
prohibitive to the players if it's 500
it it now as current law stands for a
$2,500 tournament the break on the buyin
would be $500 and that's what players
are unwilling to play to pay yes follow
but you're talking about a $500
tournament I thought that's what the 250
of the buyin amount meant no the 250
referenced here is regarding the rake so
the rake for $500 tournament for
instance the rake would be a would be
20% this is saying everything stays at
20% except it's cap at 250 so no more
rake yes represent s uh thank you um
would this put us more in line with
other states as far as their rakes are
concerned um I will have to get back
detailed information for you I certainly
can for surrounding states but I will
tell you it's very very uncommon in the
industry to have a rake that would be
table
okay thank you thank
you I have no more pink cards now um is
there anyone else who would like to
1549 okay seeing none we will close the
public
hearing all right that uh that concludes
today's agenda um tomorrow as you all
know we've got we're starting at 9:30
tomorrow just to keep that in mind we
are going to hear on six different bills
and depending on how things flow um we
we may have to have a lunch break um and
continue in the afternoon but uh we will
start with the current schedule at 9:30
going every half an hour on those bills
and then my plan um for schedule after
that after tomorrow we'll be done with
all the public hearings uh for the bills
we currently have in ways and means and
so
um next week I need to get um the
schedule in for next week by tomorrow um
I'm planning on trying to I mean I don't
know if all of you know I think we've
talked about it this room being a double
room we share with criminal justice and
we have uh Mondays and Tuesdays
allocated to us in general and they have
Wednesdays through Friday so I what I'll
be doing is trying to schedule mostly
Mondays and Tuesdays when we have a
Wednesday like we do tomorrow it's only
because uh the chair of criminal justice
has been nice enough to allow us to use
that day so um having said that I'm
going to try to schedule mostly Mondays
and Tuesdays through February accepting
the last week which is a school vacation
week um so we will we will be meeting
next Monday and
Tuesday uh I don't know the exact St
you'll have to watch the calendar I
don't know yet whether I'm going to
start at 9:30 or 10: but um that's
that's pretty much what we'll try to do
so okay questions well on
Tuesday is a democratic can't hear you
can't there's a I was just point out
that uh FYI I guess that the leadership
group in the on the Democratic side
meets on Tuesdays from 9: to 10: so at 9
9:30 a.m. start time would be would
would interfere with that okay just so
you know all right thank thank you
representative Aly I'm sorry let me go
to representative fellow sh yeah I just
have a going forward on Mondays I don't
have any concern about that except for
just this coming Monday because it
hasn't been in the calendar yet and
personally I already booked something
for that day so it does it apply to that
and is it in the morning or are we going
to do mornings or afternoons or well
it's I mean we're going to be doing what
I'm planning on doing is listing um
several work sessions uh I'll also be
listing an exec session just in case we
are able to exec something um and so it
yeah it'll start in the morning and
um uh you know either I mean given what
representative Ames just said I'll try
to start Tuesday at 10 o'clock um and
Monday I'm not sure yet maybe we'll
start at 9:30
um so
if yeah I
mean it's tough because I there's just
because particularly because it's so
short notice and then people don't
nobody knows it outside that this room
and they're not going to see it in the
calendar until
Friday they'll see it on Friday correct
um I'm going to try to schedule the next
two weeks a challenge um for this um
yeah
I repr of all me I also I have an
appointment at 1110 for dentist on
Monday next Monday the
5th I okay I'm good for and it's been
there for a long time and it'll probably
be April before I can get another
sometime I won't know when I can get it
I know uh I mean I personally um have
scheduled things on Mondays and Fridays
um but given this this double room
scenario it's we have this challenge of
working with the other let me just get
represent Southworth because half the
time I don't see I know push it out as
far as I can yeah so we want to give him
a chance I think it is going to be
tricky to schedule either way but maybe
one thing if you could put the execs on
Tuesday which we're already planning on
um I think that would really help the
execs if they're on the day we already
thought we had whereas n on a Monday
might be tricky but just something to
think about okay yeah we will try to
there is a myriad of of issues to
navigate when scheduling and try to keep
that in mind as well uh representative
leapley thank you Mr chair I I just
wanted to clarify
afternoons I just trying to clarify no I
didn't say anything about Tuesday
afternoon no we I think most likely it's
going to be um we're going to have a
lunch break both those days because
we'll have to probably do morning and
afternoon to start getting through this
um thank you so yes
is I and I would agree that we should
try to do all the exing on Tuesday since
we've already pretty well set that up if
that were possible but if it turns out
that there aren't a lot of other things
going on on a second day that would be
necessary would it be possible to just
plan one very long day on Tuesday you
know starting at 9:30 and then going to
5: or 6 or something like
that um some of it is the difficulty
early on here is going to be
that we don't know I I mean we can guess
which bills might be might be quick but
once we get into the work sessions I I
know all of us at times are surprised by
how long something can take so I
probably will list U work sessions and
exec sessions but I'll try to keep in
mind that given the short notice on this
Monday we'll try to not
EXA I don't want to say we're not going
to EXA anything on Monday I I right now
I've got to reserve that but we'll try
to stay come Monday can't come Monday
it's too late to tell My
DST okay
um yes slightly different question do
you know which um for the work sessions
do you know which ones were're going
going to start with a list of which of
the bills are you going to do them sit
down and talk about all of them all at
once or well you know take the go
through
the that's part of that's part of what
I'm working on this afternoon to figure
out which bills um this will start
getting more clear this this first pass
is a little more difficult to get going
but we'll
um I yeah so the answer is I don't know
yes anything
else lunch okay thank you everyone we'll
tomorrow